everyone thanks for coming along my name
is dawn i'm the designer of the f-type
programming language i've been a
contributor to do net over the years to
see sharp as well see shop 2.0 c-sharp
generics and a lot of you use and i'm
here today i'm very happy to be here to
talk about the world from the language
designer's perspective if you had i
think had a really wonderful selection
of talks on the functional programming
track some of them have been f-sharp
talks we've had talks about more general
things i did michael newton have you
given your talk yet was michael to see
here something he's giving a talk on a
wonderful set of testing methodologies
called FS check which could be used it's
by C sharp and F sharp code and you've
heard from Phillip yesterday about why
you should use F sharp well you should
make the switch to functional
programming so I don't I'm not here to
sell f sharp I'll be talking a little
bit about why shops feel successful and
why you can hey you know some some
examples of what makes it great but I
want to give you a more perspective of
the world from the language designer's
point of view and it's it's a talk about
language design is a strange people ok
part at this point of this talk is so
you can understand where language
designers are coming from so that when
you go and talk to Mads torgussen when
you go and talk to me when you get
responses from us on on on FS Lang
suggestions when you make when you give
input you you you you understand why
they kind of all twisted and contorted
and kind of like oh yeah I'll think
about this or I might think about that
or you know they're trying to weigh
things up and balance things and
synthesize things and put lots of
different perspectives together because
whether you're a language designer you
got like F sharp tens of thousands of
people using your thing and you get
input from an awful lot of them and you
get a lot of input from them when we
first started to productize f sharp is
about the same time that scala was
my good friend Martin Tudor ski was also
working through scalloped releases and I
wrote him and said this is gonna be this
is we're gonna get we're gonna have a
lot of feedback on this thing out we and
he wrote back saying yep it's got to be
a rough you know there's gonna be a lot
of stuff coming in and we're gonna get a
lot of influences coming in Mads of
course with c-sharp has hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of people sitting
on top and using F sharp C sharp and
they get an awful lot of Pacific awful
lot of input on that as well so what
that all adds up to when you have so
many different perspectives and so many
different influences is you you're in a
sense exposed to the great disputes of
the area of work that you that you live
in so for instance you might be exposed
to the disputes between let's just take
you know one of the really big ones that
I'll be talking about today between
functional and object-oriented
programming these are entirely different
streams of intellectual thought of
academic research of application flow up
and through the lives and all through
the different perspectives and people
that come in and they're come down in
the feedback you get and the influences
you get from all sorts of different
perspectives and you've got to you've
got your exposed to these disputes that
we have and so really sort of the
starting position of the the life of
many people working in these in these
quarterly areas the same applies in many
ways to people working on virtual
machine design you know when you design
a virtual machine you've got that same
set of different traditions and
different ideas coming in and you've got
it in the end you've got to synthesize
that and you got to make you've got to
make something that that makes the world
a better place and in many ways makes it
has to contribute and the primary sort
of message of this talk is that the act
of making a contribution in this in this
core sort of space is in active
synthesis and an active resolving
working out a new direction between out
of conflicting what seemed like
conflicting points of view so these
disputes of computer science that are
starting point and the act of making the
resolution of coming out with a new
language a new product should actually
make the world a simpler place it should
make the world a more relaxed place it
should make the world a place that's
more productive yes but it should be a
resolution of disputes now this of
course is not a great idea not not a
nada aisle not a new idea it's an old
idea because right back to this
wonderful guy who anyone who knows who
this is ends up anyone I know Thomas
does he's in the audience so this is a
philosopher called Hegel from the 1830s
incredibly influential philosopher who
the one of his very core sort of
fundamental ideas of our human life is
that progress is is through the
resolution of this what they call
dialectic between this one idea and the
opposite idea the contradictions that
come and change is not through fighting
between these ideas but change comes
through synthesis of opposing points of
view in a new direction that wasn't and
and anticipated so has anyone ever read
any Hegel anyone ever done that it's
absolutely impossible
I mean you it is so unbelievably
difficult anybody here from Barden
Wittenberg anybody here from Germany
okay anybody here from baden-württemberg
from Arabia okay well I've been told I'm
good information for my wife that only
people through this took out area of
Germany can actually understand Hegel
because he wrote in a dialect of German
so if that's probably why no one
understands him but he does he's an
incredibly influential philosopher based
around this this idea of synthesis and
change just to say that this idea of
synthesis out of opposites is it's a
very powerful idea I love the idea but
of course like all things you can take
it too far
one great thing that demonstrates this
is this this wonderful spoof paper that
Tom
petrotech pointed me to I think Thomas
is standing over there his baby he said
oh you're talking about dialectics
you're talking about resolution out of
out of conflict that opposites you mean
mustard watchers here we go must have
watch is an integrated approach to time
and food so you know time and food I
mean they're clearly you know opposites
you know and we need to find a
resolution between these contradictory
ideas and so this this is that are one
of the very first examples of sort of
taking the mickey out of out of
philosophical positions and just sort of
just saying yeah we could take these too
far we don't we can't resolve all
conflicts and differences in the world
some things are truly orthogonal and
should be just left orthogonal so
hopefully we're not doing this hopefully
we're not just kind of making the
mustard watch but we're actually making
real progress so for the rest of the
talk I'm going to be talking about both
technical and sort of sociological
things that come up in our work as
language designers and as tool
deliverers and we're talking about
things that are in in conflict in sort
of opposites and they're talking about
how we can sort of find some synthesis
between the two and that's all going to
be in the context of my work as the
f-sharp language designer and as the
deliverer of tools to to to the to the
computing world okay so I'll start with
the conflict here that that really was a
root of F sharp this is what F sharp was
about and in many ways it's what dotnet
was about right back the very the very
founding spirit of dotnet was we're
gonna have a virtual machine but it's
not going to be like Java which at the
time had very a very weak
interoperability story it had a very
weak multi-language story we're gonna
have a virtual machine that supports
multiple multiple programming paradigms
and it is going to be able to intro fix
tremely well with comm with C and then
ultimately I think dotnet has
exceptionally good interoperability
story with a whole range of things and
this is an ongoing theme for dotnet
itself in the intro interoperability
sphere you see a lot of the two
that I've gets built in the.net era is
about solving the the the interrupt sort
of dilemma and and making sure that the
tool plays well with with other tools
but for me I was a functional programmer
and I landed the Microsoft and I landed
in at the start of dotnet and as a
researcher as well and I absolutely
loved a certain kind of functional
programming I'd been strongly influenced
by the O'Connell language but I'd worked
in a whole range of other languages but
I knew there were big problems over in
the functional world and if we remember
back to that time the time roughly
speaking 2002 2003 these functional
languages that we had then wait they
were really very isolated in and and
isolated for reasons okay they were
isolated if you look at a language like
Oh camel absolutely fantastic language
absolutely fantastic virtual machine and
runtime infrastructure but because they
had their own virtual machine then it
was just difficult for them to
interoperate not that it had a good see
interoperability it was ok see calls but
other languages like the miranda's or
the Haskell's and others also had severe
interoperability problems our isolated
not interoperable and using their own
virtual machines and back in the day
some of you will remember what was
interrupt like then well the sequel's we
still use those it's fine calm still get
to use a bit Korver anyone using Korver
anyone I'm sorry I'm so sorry
so anybody else just know just just I
don't I don't even know what cover
actually did or does but it was what
interoperability the big thing of
interoperability back then lots and lots
of XML of course was the big rage for
how everything was going to interoperate
we still use that a bit but from the
point of view of functional programming
it says these things here don't get we
don't get us what we need which is a
rich ecosystem of libraries and
components we have and even these had
even these functional VM
have to design there are an
interoperability mechanisms it was the
best it was a bad situation and it meant
that there was a real contradiction in
practice between using functional
programming and using using using and
modern virtual machines okay so the F
sharp approach is it was it was seen as
crazy at the time I mean I know I know
it's it's so normal now of course people
make these languages Scala Swift Cod
learn and there's a whole lot of others
all use the same fundamental approach
that F sharp talk and and perhaps I'll
also call out a language called ml ml J
which was a predecessor to F sharp in
many ways as doing the standard ml
language to the JVM back in the late 90s
where some of my colleagues at Microsoft
Research also took this approach and it
was same people said look there's no way
you're going to get a functional
language that runs anywhere near fast
enough by running on an object-oriented
virtual machine that were just
absolutely dismissive that this idea of
taking functional programming and
sticking it on dotnet was going to was
going to work out in practice and it has
worked out I mean we were absolutely
right the Scala people were absolutely
right as well to take the the
programming paradigm is slightly
different emphasis in Scala for an
f-sharp or taking this functional
functional first programming paradigm
where tsukina on top of that net an
industry-standard runtime layer and now
the act of doing that is not just making
say Oh camel net and then sticking
rigidly this is what our camel is and
let and and this is what net is because
that doesn't give you the win-win that
you need between the the in the
ecosystem that you're in just like Scala
wasn't just taking some existing
language we really do let the
environment and sort of environment that
you're in you're walking in to influence
the language design to some degree to an
appropriate degree we have to keep the
Exorcism at an appropriate distance so
there's really a balance ii act as you
think my clique is gone
and there might be another one here
I might have to yeah here we go I'm
gonna does it still work
oh it does okay great so there's a
balancing act that you have to do as you
make a language design situated in the
dotnet ecosystem and in particular you
have to design the language with
interoperability in mind and that runs
all the way through the f-sharp language
design we do care about interoperating
with C sharp and interoperating with
dotnet dll's and interoperating more
widely as well and I'll talk about that
when we talk about type providers as
well and we do need to compromise some
elements where needed if some elements
of the approach that you know the
functional approach don't fit on the on
the platform and useful on the platform
then we won't do it on the platform okay
so this tension here we have this on a
new direction an arrow going down which
is functional on interoperable virtual
machines and it has worked absolutely
fantastically as I said it's not just an
approach used by f-sharp when you look
at the the Kotlin language design
situating in the context of the other
android well both generally but in
particular the JVM and the Android
ecosystem if you look at the Swift
language design in the Objective C
ecosystem those languages are very much
following this kind of path that has
been trodden so that's definitely a
story in relaxation I don't wake up
anymore like I did in 2003 saying I
really want to be able to have a
functional language it runs on dotnet I
really want to be able to use functional
programming practice because I can okay
that I don't have to worry about that
anymore that problem is solved and life
is Pina Colada time relaxation so so
these are these and we haven't given the
baby away these functional programming
languages are true to their principles I
think in that and so that's certainly
true for f-sharp
it says scale has a slightly different
set of design principles but they I
think it says true to the true true true
to a mixed functional object-oriented
paradigm and I'll talk about a few I'll
type
in a bit okay okay but I do want to say
that we there are some things we don't
do in F sharp up because they don't
they're not easily implemented on
industry standard virtual machines
there's a feature called higher kind of
types which is both there's also a
physical type classes they're only
they're both functional language
functional techniques and we don't do
them on an F sharp that's partly because
of implementation issues and partly
because well then in the in that context
of an interoperable context they're not
as useful as they are if you've got
control over the whole library design so
because we don't have control over the
whole net library design then then we
it's not really quite as compelling to
do those features and in fact it could
actually be a negative for in some
situations all right okay so that's a
technical feature functional and Interop
I now want to turn to a more
sociological kind of thing which is this
massive tension as a tool deliverer and
the first creating a language and
working with the community and with an
ecosystem and this is and it's a tension
which many of you have in your working
life as you work in enterprises and you
work to consider how to relate to open
source and that's this yeah this big
tension between enterprise and openness
and funnily enough I don't think we
really have a name for what this the
resolution of this thing is if we
interesting to try and think of a term
we say Microsoft's embrace open sources
open source but we absolutely haven't
given the enterprise thing away we've
created I mean and other enterprises are
doing the same thing we've we've created
something else that's in the middle that
we need a name for to say what's this
thing that you get when you combine an
enterprise and openness and in a
positive synthesis and combination so
just talk about the where we are now I
think Phillip and others have covered
this really really well
f-sharp is a language design has a I
think of as a sort of a demilitarized
zone called the f-sharp Software
Foundation and it has this kind of space
which is neutral and in the independent
it's cross-platform neutral and
independent and that means is
sort of although f-sharp is heavily
influenced by dotnet it also is used on
JavaScript extensively and it's also
although F sharps has great tooling in
Visual Studio we also have other
contributors like JetBrains who make
professional tooling for F sharp and
what it means is everybody involved in F
sharp agrees that there's this sort of
space where we consider things from a
neutral cross platform an independent
point of view and that is certainly
applies to the F sharp language design
and it also applies to many other
aspects about how F sharp works as an
ecosystem so of course we're open we
nearly I think nearly all F sharp
tooling is except all of it is accepting
contributions and is a license under
under under good licensing terms and I
said I mention F sharp already as part
of this cross-platform neutral and
independent this gives a the community a
very strong voice in the F sharp arena
there the the sort of the the community
can shape have a have a route by which
to shape what the f sharp ecosystem and
about it looks like but from a technical
and a social point of view and so that's
through the F sharp Software Foundation
which is absolutely wonderful thing on
tooling I work for a group for Microsoft
mobile tools and we sort of do dotnet
for devices which we can also call
xamarin and they we provide F sharp
tools for Android and iOS I spend a lot
of my time working out new programming
models for doing up programming and
sitting there with my Android device
happily like sort of getting the apps to
do their thing
I'll be talking a bit about that later
we have the visual F sharp tools and
Microsoft's tools for Windows and Azure
I should also I've also mentioned
JetBrains and other tooling providers
here and of course we have this it's
wonderful story for F sharp for dotnet
core which means you have a great story
on Linux and
OS X and everywhere where dotnet core
runs and also on multiple cloud
platforms we have Google cloud platform
support for F sharp through dotnet core
we have Amazon Lander support for F
sharp and and and so on and that's
largely coming through this the fact
that I've sharp is far the dotnet core
okay so underneath this at a technical
level a lot of this is driven through
this one component called the f-sharp
compiler service
it drives its Ameren tooling it drives
to visualise sharp tooling it's the core
of the compiler that's delivered through
dotnet core but it's also drives a lot
of other scenarios it's a fully open
component it also drives thing called
fable so the it's just a dll a single
DLL f-sharp compiler service or DLL that
gets included into all these different
components when we make an addition to
the f-sharp language design we're really
making an addition to this component and
then out it flows into all the different
tooling ok so a very integrated cohesive
tool tooling story we were able to float
make change here and flow it out into a
whole range of different packaging and
tooling tooling as delivery channels so
we have this wonderful thing called safe
stack as well I'll talk about that in a
bit and what all of this means ok and
it's been a lot taken us a real journey
to get to this point for f-sharp and
what all of this means is I the the
enterprise story is resolved the
openness story is resolved whatever we
call this situation where we have this
combination is a relaxing super relaxing
situation for me in that I get to
concentrate on my part of the game as
language designer down here we've this
I've been using this slide for a couple
of years but I've and that number there
has progressed from 4.0 to 4.1 to 4.5
we've been able to iteratively improve
the f-sharp language design and flow out
the changes and work with the community
on RFC's
and really make progress on the language
and really happy with where this
combination is so this shift to open
engineering I mean maybe that's a term I
could use for it we're still enterprises
we're still open source this combination
Lester's called open engineering for
this talk it happened
everyone 2014 2015 and net has gone the
same way in 2016 and I like to think we
acted as inspiration for the.net shift
to this as well and this has been really
a huge success and I'm really incredibly
happy with where we are and I think mark
Microsoft as people who originated that
shift are very happy to be part of this
so loads of run through some things
about the ramifications of that shift
just just a couple of signals that you
can pick up on so we've got loads of
pull requests have come into the F sharp
compiler including with for instance we
have JetBrains contributing to the F
sharp editing support so where that
space of cooperation between what in
some ways a different tooling vendors is
walking out you know that's and that's
that's the magic really when you get
cooperative spaces to do the open
engineering so you can take a look at
the guard ownership that github that I
owe to find out where to contribute we
have a language design process which is
to use to drive that change take a look
at FS lang design if you've got
suggestions you want to you'd be one of
those people feeding me sort of points
of view on where the f-sharp language
designs will go then drop them in on
f-sharp language suggestions or search
and vote on the ones that are there I we
take the language suggestions and turn
them into we approve them in principle
they become RFC's in f-sharp like if
it's Lang design you can read through
all the previous RFC's and comment on
them and contribute new ones and and and
then help implement them as well so so
please get involved it's a lot of fun
you quickly run through what we did in
those releases f-sharp 4.0 we well I
won't go through this in detail you can
kind of say the usual
of lists of improvements and better
nurse we did a whole lot of work on the
core library we made type providers more
powerful we did better debugging tooling
parfum provements on the compiler it's
just better nurse betterness we with
this 4.1 and 4.2 have been influenced by
this sort of this great thing internet
that you can use Struck's to get
performance increased performance we've
been doing that through making a whole
lot of unboxed options available for
various f-sharp types putting some
things in the core library we've also
solved some issues in the programming
model to allow you to do these sort of
large open scopes namespace rec like
this and i guess i can announce the
f-sharp 4.5 feature set i mean it'll
come out officially in the blog post
from philip sometime soon but this is
what is being checked into master i've
for delivery through those channels so
it's been interesting we've we've
watched the the c-sharp people go
through C sharp 7 and they they kind of
dripped out this feature by feature in
c-sharp 7.0 7.1 7.2 this kind of
features for a zone where c-sharp really
is is a is a very good choice which is
sort of this high-performance systems
programming it's a point where there's
pointers and and and and and so unmanned
unmanaged memory and kind of flat memory
structures for for programming so
middleware in a in a in a cloud in in a
cloud environment ok and what that I'd
love to is actually quite a really good
design which is a really important
contribution to the dotnet ecosystem and
we roughly think of that a span of tea
and memory of tea but it's actually made
up of a whole lot of other technical
features like by RF extension methods on
stroke strokes or by RF returns and you
know we don't need to worry about the
technical details so much but a lot of
it is about pointers here by row if this
and that and I'm making the use of flat
memory
arrays of struct objects so safer and
make these two pointers safer and so we
decided to put this into f-sharp 4.5
part because it is now part of its
really a dotnet design an f-sharp is a
dotnet language and we absolutely had to
do a good job of this as well so I'm
very happy that we've been able to land
this over the last month and it's landed
in master now and it's in it's in good
shape as a feature and if you're into
this kind of safe memory
high-performance programming then this
is a great addition you can learn and
and and use I'm happy with how this
pointer business worked out an f-sharp
so a bar F of T which exists already is
just consider the bar F where you can
read or write the thing and in ref is a
bar F which is an imprimatur which you
can only read and out ref is a is a bar
for designing an out parameter which you
only meant to write okay and that we did
a few other things down here syntax and
and and so on and now that's done we can
start to put our attention towards
f-sharp 5.0 and please get involved in
in that design okay so openness what
does this on the open aside we have
Christoph here who does the iron.i
tooling which is absolutely fantastic
tooling for the F sharp envious code a
lot of F sharp people use that every day
as their main tooling and it uses the F
sharp compiler service and I don't think
it supports atom anymore I'm not sure
that anyway it's fierce code is the main
point of use and a fantastic thing
entirely community-driven apart from the
F sharp compiler service which is also
which is that core component I talked
about openness I mean this is absolutely
amazing I've mentioned this already that
we had F sharp is our part of the.net
SDK itself and that means wherever the
dotnet core tooling appears in the world
then F sharp will be a part of that
tooling and that is an absolutely
fantastic result for spreading f sharp
it's having influence inside the company
at Microsoft where I am and if it's
having influencing companies like Amazon
and Google as they to go out neck or
tooling then F sharp goes along for the
ride
and that's absolutely fantastic so and
the wonderful thing about shifting to
open engineering and open source is you
get the incredible creativity of your
community and I'm going to just mention
there lots and lots of examples of this
in the air shaft community if you want
to see one great example of it take a
look at the F sharp advent calendar
where we at the end of the year if
you're part of the F sharp community and
you want to contribute to you know some
of the great things you've been creating
during the year then you you you you
contributed a blog entry to the F sharp
advent calendar and we get 50 60 of
those different blog entries coming out
and they're all really good to read I
mentioned two one is fable F sharp to
JavaScript via Babel and this gets used
to implement I&I two gets used for real
it's not a toy this thing is used in in
in in applications
enterprise applications it's used as I
said for various code and other things
and I strongly recommend if you're into
the JavaScript ecosystem that you
consider taking a look at fail and for
many people this is an entry point
f-sharp now not through net but through
but through Favell and javascript
programming and it's very much packet
its packaged as a node package you're
part of the JavaScript ecosystem when
you use fable but it's a great example
of the F sharp community's creativity
this is a great example not only the F
sharp community's creativity but also
their technical excellence the safe
stack here safe stack github do is it's
a functional first stack both for fable
on the client-side and net core on the
server side and f-sharp all the way and
you can share code between these two you
have a really great rapid development
process where as you save files it
automatically repopulate syou're your
web your web app with the code and the
server side as well and you get to use a
functional first perspective all the way
through so it's a great thing in and of
itself it is what the fact that is
community
driven means you get community
creativity and technical excellence all
the way through so if you're a great
programmer and you're looking and you're
either on the website or the server side
and you're looking for a place to where
your technical excellence will be
respected and where you can make a big
difference in in in in delivering a full
stack to the to the programming world
then this is a great place to contribute
and work and to learn a lot as well
okay I've talked about the F Java
compiler service so I won't do that
anymore but okay so open engineering
this is where this is how we resolve
this tension here it's a tension I think
the the computing world is going to be
continuing to have to talk about over
the next the next 10 20 30 years you
know this is this there are there are
still real questions that come up
between enterprise and openness and but
I you know these things together you
need all of these things to get the
goodness at the end enterprise quality
openness community tooling and a
flourishing ecosystem and an evolution
path for going forward and all of those
things together means again a real
source of relaxation as for people
working in the f-sharp aruna and please
join us okay so the next area
how we doing for time okay we got some
time you okay fine fine okay so the next
area of tension here what's it going to
reveal I I've run through this fairly
quickly because you've been given oh no
it's a surprise I guess a different one
first okay
well we'll do this one instead right so
let's get back to the one that started
the talk the question between functional
and object-oriented programming and yeah
let's go back in time back to the days
when these were really opposing camps I
mean there were there are still times
when the functional and object-oriented
worlds feel like they're light-years
apart and just coming from Venus and
Mars right there it's a different
different planets but on the whole it's
not like that anymore but back then it
was when we started this kind of work
so sometimes in some situations when
you're with functional diehards you
mention the word object and they
actually literally have this painful
reaction they go oh something like this
and now that does still happen a little
bit I mean this example that I
absolutely love is this book called
compiler implementation with standard ml
back from the 1990s they're also Java
versions of this and I think the C C++
version as well and every chapter had
this little tag line on it that would
say like garbage collection you know
removing unnecessary objects or
reclaiming unnecessary memory that
there's no longer gonna be used or
something very deadpan totally technical
deadpan except for chapter 14 which had
this his tag line object art appearing
object to this express a dislike or
distaste for something the whole point
of those tag lines was that he could put
that in that particular chapter and it's
which is a very it was a gem that was
hidden away okay so what's the F sharp
approach to this how do we not fall into
this trap of just like this earth trap
for this kind of like rejection kind of
thing I me some object-oriented people
have the same thing with functional
programming or whatever I'm not going to
touch that oh my god it's hard that must
be mad something crazy responds like
that which is just it's not how we get a
synthesis not how we make the world a
better place so so how do we do that
well part of it is we use a slightly
different language okay we say we have
we embrace object programming and we
sure objects are fine where are you
program with objects no problem okay and
we make it fit with expression oriented
typed functional paradigm this core
functional paradigm expression oriented
typed functional paradigm plus the
ability to use objects that's not the
same thing as object orientation okay
this is fine this I do have a little bit
of an issue with okay I want to draw
that out a little bit more of the next
few slides
so first of all technically let's have a
look at some s sharp objects here's a
nice little functional object no state
in this one we have DX and dy we have an
internal value this d2 thing here we
have a set of run through the the tags
here inputs to the object construction
here an implicit constructor that's the
object internals and part of the
constructor these are the exported
properties and these are some exported
methods down here so there's very much
this thing that things flowing at the
top it's got some internals and things
flow out through this API here for these
members that's pretty straightforward
fairly simple it's all type inferred
runs well and net interoperates etc etc
the the language features a pretty
simple constructed class types of here
interface types and I think that already
C sharp still doesn't have an object
expressions unbelievably useful I can
implement an interface here in the
middle of my code I can I can extend a
implemented class III underneath you
might be inheriting there'll be a class
created underneath it's a bit like a
closure or delegate but you know there's
which will subclass this thing and then
add these interfaces on and so on but
you don't think of it in terms of object
orientation you just think of it as
implementing and a little obstruction
and it fits incredibly well with
functional programming absolutely no
problem with this whatsoever it just
fits really beautifully and it fits very
well with type inference and and it's
it's it's it's just just using this
feature alone a lot of your boilerplate
c-sharp code will just sort of
disappears along the way
and so this is a nice set of set of
features we we have here okay but of
course the object orientation isn't just
one thing okay and you look at the
object tradition of programming
languages and Matz covered this and I
think some of the background to this and
in his keynote you kind of have to come
to object orientation as a language
designer and have to pull it apart into
lots and lots of different things like
here we have the dot
well nobody can really complain about
the dot notation okay we have our
instance members like we saw those on
the previous slide and they cetera type
direct the name resolution that you work
out what this length means based on the
type of X and etcetera etcetera we run
through all these different features and
you know since as a language designer
coming up with his synthesis you have to
take this set of features and actually
have an opinion about them and perhaps
something we haven't communicated well
enough over time is what is the F shelf
opinion on object orientation
well what that's what really this big
question is and we of course have to
make these fit with the other features
you want the functional features so when
you come to these you kind of put them
in different buckets and you say well
some of them are make F sharp a better
API language they actually genuine
improvements to F sharp and make it for
expressing api's some of it is just like
strux about implementing things
efficiently some of it is just part of
being a dotnet you're an intro part of
the Interop standard or in the context
of compiling to JavaScript you need to
interoperate with JavaScript objects and
some of them just aren't needed okay you
don't need to suck on the whole thing
just because you suck on one thing okay
so roughly speaking where we stand is
this so we take this core set of
features so you take index and notation
or static members or instance members or
interface types and implementations
optional arguments and we say sure these
are absolutely great to be using in F
sharp code you've got to use them well
you can design badly with this set of
features but yeah this makes F sharp and
outright better language to use of this
set of object-oriented features and use
them well now then there's a sort of
second bucket of things which is like
mutable data auto properties patterns
like a disposable events trucks
delegates enums and typecasting here
which f sharp would still be F sharp
without these things okay but we need
these for various reasons so it sort of
used where necessary use tastefully used
respectively respectfully and probably
use sparingly but it still okay to use
them but just be aware that don't you
do you don't it's not core to the work
it might be around the edges of your
work okay and then there's a set of
features which I've conveniently put in
red over here such as these large type
hierarchies of things it's use of
implementation inheritance in large type
hierarchies use of nulls and unchecked
default and the extensive use of method
overloading that's a bit of a spectrum
but let's say overloading methods
ambiguously based on type and and number
of arguments and these are you know this
is where you're going down the rabbit
hole if you embrace this stuff too much
this is a heavy heavy object orientation
over this side and we say probably not
in F sharp there are some cases where
you might still use some of these things
but probably not and then there's a set
of things we just don't over do we just
don't do we don't actually don't support
protected because sitting and the reason
we don't support protected is because it
encourages implementation inheritance
and only works in the context of
implementation inheritance and I don't
like that okay I don't want to be let
people to be led towards implementation
inheritance wildcard types and aspect
oriented programming and so on okay so
we don't do those not supported so
roughly speaking love these tolerate
these mostly avoid these and forget all
about this okay and then you'll be then
you'll be happy and you get on get on
with your programming life and that's
the difference now between object
programming which f-sharp does support
and that's about succinct coding
notational convenience
you know c-sharp has done a great job of
being an API design language okay and
you can do all those things in F sharp
so it's about API
ergonomics good naming practical
encapsulation sensible small composable
abstractions this is all good in the
context of object oriented object
programming with F sharp and it fits
well with being an expression oriented
and above all and the most important
thing of all is it focuses on making
simple
things out of complex foundations okay
so that you can and that is often done
out of delegation you make something
simple you capture it as in your closure
of things or in your object design and
you make a simple API which delegates
towards complex foundations okay
object-oriented programming on the other
side it says object is going to be a
single dominant paradigm that effects
both you all the way from your
implementation all the way up to T or
your Mel diagrams and object objects
objects absolutely everywhere its
massive overuse of higher classification
starting with the very first page of
those design books I don't know what it
is about people they just wanna that
once you give them the ability to
hierarchically classify things they just
start classifying the entire world sort
of obsessively you know they start with
animal and then by you know you know
they discontinue to do that I think it's
a it's must be something in cognitive
that encourages that people have this
natural facility to to draw to put
things into into buckets and then draw
connections between them
okay so overuse of hierarchical
classification object-oriented
programming has often large abstractions
with loads of failure points ok loads of
nulls or loads of places where things
sort of don't work ok and in
implementation inheritance where if you
start with something complex and you
inherit from it then you can only make
it more complex ok implementation
inheritance encourages the creation of
complexity ok because you're making
complex things out of complex things ok
and that is the fundamental reason why I
don't I don't fully embrace
object-oriented programming
ok at a technical level that that means
you have these all these functional
features here and then you have all
these object features down here and
you've got to work out how they all
interact and a lot of the F sharp
language design is about getting this
right you're getting all these tick
boxes and they're making some careful
limitations around the edges down the
down the bottom I won't go through those
but you sort of get this relative
relatively graceful degradation so you
might need some type annotations over
here or you
if you use a combination of features and
the same with down here okay
and then some combinations it's outlawed
here we don't allow currying here and
method overloading okay so that is again
a positive synthesis there are some
limitations and sorry that that comment
is from an old talk I'm not going to be
talking about this here but there's a
strong positive synthesis between those
things okay so in the last fifteen
minutes I just want to run through a
couple of slides on how we make
functional programming practical in in
in in so this object orientation I've
talked about that we go from functional
to functional first programming I think
the others figures have covered this
well so f-sharp people love these kind
of aspects of code succinct expressive
and so on some examples of code that we
love is a that's an F sharp program nice
and succinct and small and we love our
pipelines like this here you will have
seen these in other talks we take
something we go pipe pipe pipe all day
long and half of F sharp code looks
looks like this
we also F sharp is absolute people
absolutely love their domain modeling
code so I think Scott relation has has
covered this well we take some you know
a lot of F Java code starts with his set
of type definitions at the top of the
file which represents the domain model
and then the rest is a semantic for that
domain and about half of the blog posts
on the F sharp advent calendar kind of
series are about sort of using F sharp
for domain modeling and then capturing
the core essence of the domain and then
running through that and so here are
some examples of that this is a sort of
data structure that's coming back from a
web web service and OD and Nigeria here
has a great great comment about this
your choice of data structure and your
design to remain is crucial when writing
F sharp code screw it up and you'll be
walking around in circles
naylet and your implementation will be
concise straightforward and perhaps even
trivial and that that is true in
practice two great books I'd recommend
I'm a modelling made functional and get
programming with f-sharp there's also a
book I wrote called expert f-sharp
if you're interested particularly in
domain modeling and semantics then these
are great books an area that I've been
working on lately is in this use of
functional programming for the view of
of you eyes so you have this view this
is elvish what's called elvish coat as
part of Fable and you have a view
function and it simply returns depending
on some the values in some current model
it either returns this view or returns
this view and this is obviously a little
DSL for HTML we have to have div and a
string div div a class time container
button here with a on click event here
which will dispatch a message called
faster here back around the loop and
this another one dispatch slower there
okay so that's great so you get to write
your this beautiful sort of functional
you might sort of a variation on
functional reactive programming every
time there's a change to the model the
view gets reevaluated so I'm working a
lot on making this real in the context
of mobile app and xamarin programming
you can look at a thing called el mesh
Dameron forms and here's what the view
function looks like if the model if the
button is being pressed then you say
label text I was pressed and otherwise
you have a button you say press me and
then a very similar thing you dispatch
around the loop here so that's a mobile
app view and that lets you have sort of
a mobile app in a single file you have
your set of messages here which coming
back either external or from the user
interface you have your model press here
you have your initial model the button
was impressed you have an update
function what will go to the view first
you have review which you've already
seen and it dispatches those messages
and then we have this update here which
when the message is pressed the press
becomes true that's your full
application code you tie it together at
the bot
in your app and you have your mobile app
in a single in a single file and the
back you go to Android or iOS or and you
can also run on Mac and WPF and and and
other and other systems everywhere the
xamarin forms is supported it's early
days yet with this it's a community
project on f its projects in this
incubation space so if you into mobile
programming if you've done some xamarin
or if you've done some Android iOS come
along and join in and and and use use
this it's a lot of fun I found it
incredibly simplifying for for for doing
xamarin and mobile programming okay
f-sharp people love their composition
like this here this is uh from Craig so
inside our CF community for code that
they love and Craig sent me this one
it's not fancy but often get giddy
smiles when people see it they get the
giggles the top level of the compiler is
exactly like you're taught Lex pass by
and optimized code gen is a bit of
railway or into programming by Scott or
lash and at the end here because these
last few phases might have a failure
point and you just get that lovely
pipeline down through the code okay back
on and just to mention that the
functional first approach does make a
huge difference and you can look at F
sharp that all the testimonials I'll
skip this and just mention one one
example of this and that is let's see
here we have this three billion dollar
unicorn company built on f-sharp the jet
comm was acquired by Walmart and for a
deal worth three billion and they're
pretty much entirely an F sharp shop you
talked in heel here used to work at jet
about the background for the use of F
sharp and why they chose F sharp and why
they were able to build such an
incredibly successful company on it and
it is the first unicorn built on the
Azure platform from the Microsoft
perspective and business perspective is
absolutely huge result
it shows that Azure is ready for
building incredible business value and
and delivering it all the way through ok
so the functional first programming
really does work in practice it's a
functional programming is no not some
academic thing you modify it to make
sure it's practical and you have
functional first and everything is is
great okay in the last five minutes I'll
just talk about one one more area of
tension it's more a technical area and
it's basically retained the tension
between code and data back in the around
2010 2011 those were that marks off
research really saw that there was a big
shift going on in the in the world okay
where where the companies had to be much
much more data data focused okay this
the the there this shift had been going
on in sort of the database world that
suddenly became absolutely pervasive
that the working life of of most
programmers was no longer it used to be
the day that when you start the old joke
that okay you guys get coding while i
work out what we have to do okay there
was that in order to be a programmer
there was a whole lot of code that you
wrote you know whatever that was sort of
generic and and then there's a problem
you needed to do and then you need to
code code code but it's different these
days and that data is an integral part
of everybody's working life so it's no
longer about coding it's about like
what's my data what are we
interoperating with what yeah and that
that's pervasive in loads and loads of
different ways and what it means is it
you know if you talk about one large
company right these are not exact
numbers but they're just sort of scale
of things well for every for every one
person working on tooling for code it's
probably ten people working at Microsoft
on tooling for data ok I don't know that
that's a totally rough guesstimate but
that's you know we all think about code
and visual studio or what other other
kinds of tooling the whole time but data
tooling is this vast endeavor and its
course it's vastly important and that's
all because of this you know we are
today all you know we live at an
incredible point in history of this
information revolution and so where did
that leave us from
programming language perspective do we
just ignore that okay do we just ignore
this sort of tension between code and
data well an f-sharp we did something
about it
okay and that was we took the approach
we have to be able to bring information
into the language in a very generic way
and we have to be able to do that at
internet scale arbitrary scale and we
have to be able to do it strongly told
and strongly typed and that's the
fundamental thing we recognize them
we've had to be have to be able to solve
this problem and I don't think any other
language is solved it as well as f-sharp
in the context of strong typing and to
do that we had to sort of blur the lines
between static and dynamic some people
make statically type everyone was trying
to do this but we actually didn't do
what other people some people tried to
make statically languages more dynamic
some people try to make dynamic
languages more static instead we well we
change the idea of static typing and we
apply it very broadly and that leads to
this thing called their sharp tie
providers then they look just like a
library but they're actually a plug-in
to your compiler and your editor tooling
it ok that computes a type space of
types and methods on demand it's like
computing a dotnet library on demand
okay so it's adapter between data and
services and on demand you produce this
dotnet type type system so on demand
scalable compile time provision of type
definitions so if the Internet's you've
seen examples of F sharp type providers
of the top here people typing in code
over some data source in this case it's
a CSV and then which has the same schema
as some external data source and you get
strong
intellisense here immediately on your on
your on your data source you've seen
examples of those I won't go through
through the other one so but what it
means is this one general mechanism lets
us do loads and loads of different data
sources with one with one mechanism all
your types are belong to us is what we
what we you
we were calling it that's the example
you've seen here loading data from this
web service and getting strong typing
through to it automatically so it's
literally used this sample data as the
schema so you're drawing types from
samples and every data source you come
across typically has sample data that
it's as its documentation you can often
just use that sample data like the
samples you get back from the github web
API for example and and use that to
generate your types on demand and and
get your strong typing for your data
source you do the same thing with JSON
data here we have a sample being drawn
directly from a Web API okay and then
that's the actual runtime thing so we
load here a some provider over that
sample and then we get strong typing
over that JSON data you can do the same
thing with XML do the same thing with
sequel there's a couple of variations on
sequel here this is one called sequel
data connection this is actually a
different type of atom where you
actually put your sequel here and it
gets strongly checked at compile time by
talking to the database through the
connection string and so you're kind of
getting strong checking for your sequel
at compile time here which is a pretty
rare and very productive embedding of
sequel into your into your language you
could do it with big data systems have
done samples for Hadoop and hive you can
do it with web api's like this World
Bank API here and you can do it for
entire entity graphs it's an old sample
called freebase you can do it for old
fashioned web services like this one
here you get again strong typing my
location latitude is strongly typed
there you can even do it for intro
operating with other programming
languages like the our provider so that
if you've got our install on your system
and you want to use those libraries then
you can use you can use the our provider
some
said actually I mean typewriters are
absolutely great I think it's a crucial
problem here's a quote from a professor
who about the core idea of tie providers
integrating internet scale information
services directly into the program's
variable and type space okay that's kind
of the that's the core idea and it's a
core idea that is necessary at this time
in in in the development of programming
languages and what this means by doing
one thing one mechanism and having so
many different applications of it
there's a whole lot of things we don't
need to worry about in F sharp anymore I
mean we actually have to build those
type providers which is an art in itself
but we we don't have to keep extending
the language - it's a interoperate with
XML we don't have to keep mcc's sending
it to have to interoperate with json or
etc etc etc we've got one mechanism that
close with loads of different
integrations of data into the language
okay right so just to mention to finish
up there are other areas where the same
thing applies I won't go through the
details but technical areas like this
and the language design we have you know
we've made a big contribution in the
development of async programming and
again it's a contribution to get those
things to fit and to fit well and with
units of measure is the same sort of
thing and I've talked about fable and
getting a win-win between these kind of
systems and this is you know a proof
that this sort of full stack kind of
approach is a good synthesis of this
kind of problem okay so just to finish
up as you go through your working life
remember the Hegel don't try and read
him you can try read him if you've
managed to then let me know that's great
but remember this that when you have
opposing points of view there is
hopefully some sort of synthesis that
you can find to make the world a better
place that might play out in lots and
lots of different ways I've tried to
give you examples of how that applies we
do live in a world of lots of
conflicting choice
ideas techniques you know politics is is
incredibly polarized today and it's
really hard to find a way through that
towards a middle ground but this idea
the synthesis and contradiction is what
applied programming language design is
really about and I encourage you if
you've got these conflicts resolve your
conflicts they're what making you you
know whether that's by designing a
programming language or contributing to
a design or however that happens resolve
your inner conflicts and hopefully that
leads you to a lovely state of
relaxation and happiness and thank you
very much we're taking questions or
maybe not no no questions okay